foreign
[Music]
face scanners locked phones DNA samples
and a public threat to hecklers all
standard protocol at Joe Rogan's new
comedy club well maybe not the DNA
samples but still out of any comedy
venue to ever exist the comedy
Mothership has the most extensive
security by a mile which has the
internet asking has Joe Rogan gone too
far before we take a closer look at
these rules let's quickly try to put in
perspective what the comedy Mothership
really is starting off with the caliber
of stars that are coming through these
doors every single night of the week
like Joe Rogan Dave Chappelle Pete
Davidson plus whatever A-list celebrity
is rebounding with him at the time
regardless of what you think of their
jokes these are some of the most famous
comedians in the world and they're
showing up to perform at this club not a
theater not an arena it's a small
intimate 100 seed Club the rooms do
separate things for committed growth
that little room teaches intimacy and
connection yeah you can't just go up
there and say words you have to connect
with them sometimes in big rooms you can
just say words and you don't have to
connect because the connection is a
little bit off there's a little bit of a
filter so you can perform so the small
room they get to learn how to really
[__] put your foot on somebody you
can't truly be the comedy Mothership
without all the biggest names wanting to
come by and for that to happen they
gotta feel safe or maybe all this is
overkill I mean seriously it's not like
anyone would ever want to rush the stage
or try to hurt one of these guys right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Joe Rogan's not photographing audience
members so he can build some secret
database of Austin comedy fans half the
shit's probably just to make people less
inclined to try to [__] up the show you
wouldn't rob a bank that just took a
picture of your face with the level of
celebrities that have been deemed
problematic by the mainstream media that
are going to be performing at this club
on a regular basis there's bound to be a
few brainwashed Psychopaths that only
buy a ticket so they can yell at Dave
Chappelle all I'm saying is if you know
the comedy club you just walked into
scanned a picture of your face you're
going to be way less inclined to start a
scene during the show curbing that issue
before it ever starts these rules also
allow every comedian performing there to
feel safe eager to be there and
confident in giving their best
performance without worrying about
anyone being distracted by their phones
or even worse filming their jokes out of
context the way it works is I say stuff
that is the wrong thing to say I hear
the resistance to it and then I and then
I work with it and work with it and it
takes a few shows for it to be a safe
bit to do but it's not for regular
consumption it's like watching somebody
practice piano yeah and and going like
he sucks I think it's really bad that we
don't have these barriers anymore where
there's speech that's for these few
people there's speech we're gonna we're
gonna have a fun conversation where
we're gonna get a little crazy it's not
for the whole world to see in fact
modern comedy would not be nearly as
good without extra precautions like
locking up phones of audience members
Chris Rock was only able to work out his
latest Will Smith material at The Comedy
Cellar in New York because they locked
the phones just think if that option
wasn't available to him TMZ would have
their hands on a video of all these
jokes a second he tried them on stage
ruining not only the special but also
his ability for those jokes to be worked
out crafted and perfected into their
final form before being seen by millions
by far the dumbest take I've seen by the
straw graspers looking for literally
anything to hate about this club is the
claim that the sign saying hecklers will
be alienated is somehow prohibiting
people's Free Speech it's an outer space
themed comedy club that has a sign to
remind people that heckling is not part
of stand up unless you're a complete
[__] imagine getting upset at a sign
that encourages people not to ruin a
show that everyone else paid money to
see do you get mad at stop signs too for
the people who know nothing about comedy
this may seem like a lot and you might
even think Joe Rogan is being a little
hypocritical based on how he speaks
about individual freedoms on his podcast
but if you actually think about what the
reasoning Behind these rules could be
it's actually the coolest thing ever and
I can't wait to see all the content that
comes out of the comedy Mothership make
sure you subscribe thank you for
watching
foreign
[Music]